шановні народні депутати дорогі
українські народи
Чим живе зараз Україна
одне об'єднуюче слово Контрнаступ
Контрнаступ на півдні
Контрнаступ на сході
нарешті позиції
жодного кроку назад
і немає для нас більш важливішої справи
ніж підтримка збройних сил України
це є оновлення
пошкоджене під час контрасту збройні
техніки
забезпечення снарядами
поставку нової артилерії
і для всього цього потрібні гроші
ворог планував на 11 вересня
по всій окупованим територіям провести
референдум
наші збройні сили зірвали ці плани
божевільного диктатора
і будуть зривати нові дати які він
спробує поставити це стало можливим
завдяки
збройним силам України
і справжнім мірилом дії кожного а тим
більше в цій залі як допомогти збройним
силам єдність
це має продемонструвати наш зал але
єднісні слава слові і єдність не в тому
що ми
будемо уникати тверезої оцінки ситуації
Що дозволить нам всім приймати правильні
рішення
єдність це спільне знаходження рішення
І от нам пропонують зараз підвищити
акцизм що уповільнить економіку що
створить проблеми фермера щоб підніметь
цими бо ще до нашого голосування ціни на
заправках вже почали зростати і замість
того щоб відмовитися від цієї
божевільної ідеї
взяли намагається її просувати для чого
може для того щоб дати армії додаткові
кошти ні для того щоб відновити великих
крадівництво воно небезпечно не лише в
зв'язку з корупцією
з тим що якщо буде повернута до
попередніх практик
партнери не будуть давати Україні гроші
і Отже ми вимагаємо
Зупинити цю ганебну практику припинить
класти асфальт в Бучі там де ми
відновлені будівлі для того щоб іти і
переживати зиму це не допустимо
зупинимо робимо те щоби об'єднало на всі
і Разом рухаємося до перемоги Дякую
Слава Україні